[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and the
next generation of gaming consoles is
finally almost upon us we got the ps5
reveal not too long ago when we got that
event with all the exclusive games and
the teasers and the hardware reveal and
everything we saw the two different
versions
everything's very dramatic now i was
going to wait typically i wait until i
have a device in my hands before i can
at least give my first impressions of it
let alone a review but pretty much
non-stop since that event people have
been asking me about it talking about it
and there's just so much conversation to
be had from that reveal so maybe let's
have that conversation now the one main
thing sony did not reveal
at that event
was the price of the ps5
[Laughter]
i have some some guesses and there's
some rumors floating around and we'll
get to that for sure in this video but
generally yeah they didn't reveal the
price officially or the release date
bummer but there is still a lot to say
about what we did see and what did get
revealed now i'm a ps4 user myself some
of you might not know that but that was
it's actually my first gaming console
ever and my current gaming console of
choice so i've been looking forward to
ps5 and seeing what it would bring seven
years later um i've also been keeping my
eye on xbox series x but that's a whole
separate video so for ps5 first of all
the design
the controversial design
i'm not gonna lie
i kind of do like it and i'm sure you
guys will all have your own thoughts in
the comments it seems like people either
love it or hate it
kind of like the cyber truck
but there is a lot to actually think
about that goes into the design of a new
console number one is how big is it
because it's gotta fit underneath a tv
or somewhere where the previous box
would have fit and there's no scale here
in the announcement but you know there's
a lot of educated guesses being made
based on the size of the disk drive and
those guesses peg it as basically the
biggest console ever it's really tall so
then naturally question number two is
can it go sideways and yes officially it
can go sideways and this is the only way
it'll fit under my tv but then just
subjectively i think it kind of looks
like a
futuristic version of what you might
expect a next-gen console to look like
from some alien planet or whatever but
they really leaned into this aesthetic
and it trickles down to the controller
and the headphones and everything else i
actually think the xbox series x looks
better i think it looks more modern and
minimal even though it's more boring if
that makes sense though then again maybe
there's been some mock-ups if sony made
a black version of the ps5 i think it
would change a lot more minds to get
more people on board especially because
white plastic doesn't have the best
reputation for aging well and people
keep their consoles for several years so
that could be interesting to see down
the road
i'm sure dbrand will have a field day
with this one though okay so there's two
versions the regular ps5 and then the
playstation 5 digital edition that's
just missing the optical drive i thought
it was kind of funny that so many people
were caught off guard by there being
these two different versions but it
actually makes perfect sense for several
reasons first of all i
and and people like me will be getting
the digital only version i have a good
enough internet connection that i
download all my games i've never bought
a physical game and i don't need the
blu-ray player so i'll get the digital
version that's fine but there are
definitely people who will buy this
console who one don't have amazing
internet connections and can't download
every single game and so they have a
physical games collection and two people
who literally use this console as their
only blu-ray player my ps4 is my only
blu-ray player right now now i don't
have any blu-rays and i don't use them
but ps5 is a 4k blu-ray player and for a
lot of people that's also pretty useful
so the digital version that i'll be
getting it looks a bit more elegant you
know it doesn't look like they finished
the design and then remembered oh
right forgot we have to put an optical
drive on there somewhere we'll just
stick it over to the side here
but then with that missing part it'll
also most definitely be a bit cheaper
matter of fact let's just get to the
price let's just talk about the price
for a second
the rumors
are all over the place so the ps3
launched for 5.99
then the ps4 launched for 3.99 back in
2013. and so now people are saying with
all these new incredible capabilities
and all these expectations sony didn't
announce the price because it's going to
be super expensive probably like a
thousand bucks or something but that i
don't know i don't think so i think and
there's some rumors of course to back
this up and potentially leaks as well i
think but i think it'll cost
4.99
for the ps5 and possibly 3.99 for the
digital only edition
something like that and i don't even
think just removing the optical drive
has to be a hundred dollar difference it
might be something like 499 and 449 for
the digital only versus the the main ps5
somewhere like that like just with the
history of pricing for these consoles if
sony wants 100 million people to impulse
buy and upgrade from their ps4s they
can't really charge
700
800 bucks or more for this console i
could see it being in the 500 something
ballpark but anything higher than that
seems unlikely so
then again all of this
is tbd they didn't yet announce that
price the actual tech inside of the ps5
is also of course a big upgrade from the
seven-year-old ps4 as you'd expect it's
all solid state storage now instead of a
hard drive i think that's the biggest
difference but it's also an amd 8-core
cpu and a 10.28 teraflop variable
frequency gpu and there's 16 gigs of ram
in there some people including some
youtubers even my friend austin evans
are comparing the the power of the ps5
to that of a modern day like straight up
tower desktop gaming pc
and i don't quite see it there yet i
think obviously something with a smaller
body like that doesn't quite have the
thermal envelope it can't really match
the raw power
of a gaming pc
but the thing about the games here's the
thing about the games
these games can develop and optimize for
every little detail every maximum of the
ps5
because everyone playing these games has
the same ps5 whereas if you're
developing a pc game for example
optimization's a bit harder there's so
many various different parts and
compatibilities anywhere from a 200 to a
2 000 tower could be playing your game
that's much harder so you can expect
these new ps5 games to have much better
lighting ray tracing better textures and
just overall bigger better maps and more
realism
we saw a ton of this in that teaser live
stream i think the games look pretty
good for the most part not all
dramatically like next-gen real or
anything mind-blowing to the point where
i feel like i need it now
but you know they look like next-gen
games better than ps4 games honestly
there were only two games in that huge
teaser trailer event that i really cared
about and they're very different
nba 2k 21
and gran turismo 7.
so the nba 2k 21 trailer was
a bit cringy if i'm being honest like to
me it's pretty obvious that they're
nowhere near done with the game they
didn't show any real game play it was
just a teaser of zion williamson
potential future face of the nba in a
really dramatically lit gym staring down
absolutely no one sweating profusely
and then dunking and that's pretty much
it like when you're playing the gameplay
itself you'll never see all this
dramatic lighting and this sweat but for
the teaser they're like we gotta add as
much glistening sweat as possible but
gran turismo i think looked really good
this looks like a game that's a lot
closer to done first of all but it looks
like a game that's going to take full
advantage of the ps5 in a lot of ways
and they showed much more of what looked
like you know typical gameplay and this
is a game where you want it to be as
realistic as possible so you go all out
with lighting and reflections and detail
all over the map and of course now the
ssd and the new hardware can handle all
that ps5 also supports 120 hertz 4k
or 8k output so the future proofing is
definitely real here now i don't have
128 hertz or 8k tv at home
like most people don't but gran turismo
7 seems like the kind of game that would
do great at high refresh rate i would
love to play it at 120 fps for better
reaction times and just a more
responsive feel looks super good also i
just thought of this just as a side note
i hope
the ps5 is quieter
than the ps4 i don't know how many of
you guys have a ps4 but if you'll notice
after like half an hour of playing 2k or
really anything
the fans are spinning 100 like it sounds
like a jet engine about to take off and
obviously with these games taking full
advantage of the ps5 again it's probably
pushing it to the limits i just hope it
doesn't have the same acoustic problem
as the ps4 but also just for fun i
looked at another game that wasn't in
the trailer uh the golf game
pga 2k21
and it looks
nowhere near as good as the ones that
were teased there's some uh some some
teaser gameplay on their youtube channel
i'll link it below that like button but
look at the golfer
look at the crowds i mean that
that just to me that doesn't scream wow
next gen gaming really enabled this to
happen like you do have better textures
and shading of the grass and and
everything's clearly a bit better than
last year but yeah there's going to be a
wide range of games and how they take
advantage of all this new hardware
overall though from what's been revealed
i'm excited i'm excited for better
looking more realistic games generally
and and the franchises that i'm used to
playing getting better and also from all
the the other titles they've committed
to just maybe trying out one or two
other games that look really fun just
because i guess we have more time on our
hands now but hey let me know what you
guys think in the comments section below
i know we're kind of stepping out of the
usual element here given impressions of
something before we actually get it this
is probably what sony wants um but trust
me when we do get it in here there will
be an impressions there will be a full
review make sure to subscribe to see
that if you haven't already when it
comes out either way i'll leave it at
that thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
you